my brother was a disc jockey and he  built his own radio station and he would  play  all these incredible albums from the  late 60s and of course he played the let  it be album yeah  and he played across the universe and i  must have been four years old and i  remember being frozen paralyzed  listening to that music yeah pools of  sorrow waves of joy yes and it just it's  my favorite song ever written  which is why i'm gonna announce some big  news for everybody wait what um i i'm  gonna have a little girl i know  i know that oh  [Applause]  it's a girl yeah and uh and her name  because of across the universe her name  is going to be lennon  lennon auggie augie for my father and  i'll i'll call her lenny for short but i  love that  thank you  that's so exciting yeah i'm thrilled  it's gonna be a girl dad it's gonna be  the biggest adventure of my life so here  we go